I cannot believe if I'm in a category
alongside these women one of them who is
my co-star Sandro safe to say Sundra
that this colony of journey has been an
absolute whirlwind and I feel so lucky
to have shared the whole experience with
you oh man yeah so Jody comer took home
the award for Best Lead Actress in a
Drama Series which meant or killing
Ecostar Sandro lost again now there's no
bad blood between them take a look at
Jody making your way to the stage to
accept your award and a very unexpected
win she shares a hug with Sandra's yeah
no love lost there now people really
thought this was Sandra's ear so Sandra
lost her season whine of killing Eve she
lost a Claire Foy for the crown that was
the last chance to give Claire the award
for her role as Queen Elizabeth the
second did other chances to give sander
the award but nope they went with
Sandra's co-star instead now I love
Sandro but Jody did stand out more in
season 2 of killing Eve they both gave
incredible performances but Jody really
kind of stole the show but man sander
lost for Grey's Anatomy five times she
actually lost this year in another
category as well Best Guest Actress in
the comedy series for when she hosted
Saturday Night Live so Sandra is now an
8 time Emmy nominee with no wins to hang
we love you Sandra and clearly Jody was
not expected to win my mum and dad were
in Liverpool who I didn't invite because
I didn't think this was going to be my
time
one I'm sorry - I love you I'm gonna
bring it home